hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the common
criticisms that gets made against egoist
perspectives in moral theory is that
they can't take into account love and
friendship and the values that these
ought to hold for us as human beings and
I'm Rand considers this in Chapter three
of her work the virtue of selfishness
which is about the ethics of emergencies
there's a really nice short discussion
there about the nature of love and
friendship and what is going on when we
for example make sacrifices or take
others into account and the charge
that's made typically goes like this and
it's not just against a you know ego
it's like Rand it's also against
hedonist of various sorts the Epicureans
have this thrown against them in ancient
times it's one thing to say that we
don't owe anything say to strangers or
even perhaps to our neighbors that were
not that close with but what about close
personal relationships don't we have a
moral duty to show affection and respect
and even love in the context of romantic
relationships or spousal relationships
or friendships or whatever it would
happen to be when we become close
the person when we become intimate with
them then we cease to value them solely
insofar as they please us or satisfy our
desires or cater to our preferences or
further our interests and we come to
value them for their own sake I mean
ideally we'd value everybody similarly
but you know for the egoist let's go
with a the easy sell what about this
person who matters to you your sibling
your parent your friend your lover don't
they matter to you beyond just the scope
of your own self-centeredness and the
worry here is that you know friendship
love all these things would indeed be
just purely self-centered and
essentially transactional where you you
know you love somebody because you find
them to be a suitable erotic partner you
want to propagate your genes with them
or you want to get off with them that is
enjoy sexual pleasure or you want them
to hang on your arms we call it arm
candy right to increase your prestige or
something like that
similarly with friends you're friends
with somebody so long as they invite you
to the parties but as soon as they get
cancer and are no longer fun at we're
done with the friendship and this would
seem to be something like you know lower
forms of friendship as described in
classical ethics the in friendships of
pleasure or utility not friendship in
terms of the person him or herself so
this is a significant issue that has to
be grappled with the common view that
that Rand is concerned about is that
love and friendship are essentially
unselfish and perhaps even disinterested
so if I love my wife I should be ready
to sacrifice at any moment my own desire
is my own needs my own wishes my own
interests my own inclinations to make
her
happy or prevent her from being unhappy
so let's say you know let's take a silly
example right she loves a certain kind
of flower and I know that getting that
will make her happy not only is it
expensive but also I happen to be
allergic to that sort of flower but I go
to the flower store anyway and I take
the money than I would otherwise be
using on buying myself you know
expensive beer or cigars or something
like that oh I'm gonna sacrifice this
fur for her and and I bring the things
home and they're underneath my nose and
I'm smelling them in and I'm like oh
these terrible flowers now my eyes are
watering it stuff like that and I get
there and I get that in writing here you
go honey and she's like oh lovely I'm so
happy that you bought me the we'll call
them allergy flowers right that's the
way that that some people do in fact
think about love you know the more that
you you give the more that you love
right so sacrificing yourself and your
own interests your own desires shows the
love or care or affection or friendship
and I'll mention another thing that
she's not talking about here but it does
come up in other contexts and that is
grief when the person is you know absent
let's say through death and you'll never
be able to see them again do you you
know should you tear your hair out and
cry till your eyes are red and can't cry
anymore and stop eating people did this
in the Middle Ages sometimes people
actually did die of grief or the results
of it you know because they indulge
themselves in these pretty wild
expressions of it some people think that
if you don't do that sort of thing it
means you didn't care about the person
and they take that as an index again
self-sacrificing behavior becomes the
proxy for whether you actually feel love
or affection or friendship Rand says no
that's a misguided way of looking at
things
she says love and friendship are
profoundly personal selfish values and
she goes on and says love is an
expression and assertion of self-esteem
we're going to get to that in a moment
these are personal values we feel love
affection friendship towards other
persons as the person who we are and
even if we took the you know the
viewpoint of love where it's supposed to
be totally self-sacrificing if I had a
terrible wife who wanted me to sacrifice
for my sacrifice my own interest for her
all the time she would want them to be
my interests right not the interests of
somebody else but my own it would be
personal but Rand is saying no no love
in a good sense is profoundly personal
and it's selfish friendship is selfish
how does this work how can this make
sense
so she says love is an expression and
assertion of self esteem self esteem
it's important to keep in mind for Rand
is a value and it leads to the virtue of
pride it's it's a capacity to value
oneself properly so an expression or
assertion of one's own self esteem one's
own self valuing and you see those same
values in another a response she says to
one's own values in the person of
another so this implies that in order
for you to feel love or a friendship to
another person you have to see at least
the potential of the same values the
same shared as she's calling it
hierarchy of values the way in which we
order and prioritize things in our lives
in the other person and without this I
mean we could have an attractiveness to
the other person we could think that
they're different than they
we could enjoy things that we do with
them whether it be you know eating
popcorn and watching movies or talking
about things and fandom or nerd dumb or
jumping into bed and having athletic sex
or you know listening to records
together whatever it happens to be right
but unless we actually share in values
unless when we are in the process of
self-discovery and discovery of who the
other person is unless there's that
commonality there we're not really going
to be in love love in the genuine sense
involves that she also thinks that
friendship involves that as well
she thinks that here we go we express
and uphold and translate our values into
practical reality we see how a person
lives and then we come to see that they
have the same values of us as we do she
also talks about taking personal selfish
joy from the existence of the other
person and this is different than just
getting something out of them this is
again recognizing a valuable Ness to the
other person and seeing that they matter
so she should get some interesting
examples here she says concern for the
welfare of those one loves is a rational
part of one's own selfish interests if a
man who is passionately in love with his
wife spends a fortune to cure her of a
dangerous illness it would be absurd to
claim that he does it as a sacrifice for
her sake not his own and that it makes
no difference to him personally and
selfishly whether she lives or dies he
does value her existing which of course
she values as well but he values her
existing for him now this raises of
course the question well what about if
you were
to be called upon to do some some action
that is going to impinge on your own
interests and it's going to be for the
person who you love and you're never
gonna see that person again they're
gonna be off in another country and
you're not going to be able to go there
should you do that and Rand would say
yeah I mean that's we're in the ethics
of emergencies the more you value the
person the more you will in fact be
willing to risk not because you have a
duty to do so but because that's an
expression of what she calls integrity
so she goes a little bit later on
she says the virtue involved in helping
those one loves is not selflessness or
sacrificed but integrity integrity is
loyalty to one's convictions and values
it's the policy of acting in accordance
with one's values translating them into
practical reality and she has a great
example here if a if a man professes to
love a woman yet his actions are
indifferent inimical or damaging to her
there's a lack of integrity she says and
she goes on she says this lack of
integrity makes him in more immoral and
why would she say that because integrity
is itself a virtue which ran thinks is
incredibly important she also talks
about a man who is able to swim and save
his drowning wife but then it becomes
panicky gives in to an unjustified fear
and lets her drown spends his life in
loneliness and misery misery she says we
would condemn him morally for his
treason to himself and to his own values
his failure to fight for the
preservation of a value crucial to his
own happiness namely the value of his
wife's life that he could have saved so
there is a personal selfish joy from the
existence of the other and not merely
their bare existence but their existence
as a human being as an agent as a career
as a thinker a reasoner as somebody else
who does these things she also talks
about incorporating the welfare of the
other person into one's own hierarchy of
values and she uses that phrase
hierarchy of values several times in
this essay that is not something unique
to Rand
there were quite a few philosophers in
the early 20th century who talked in
terms of a hierarchy of values mock
Schaller would be a prime example of
this a lot of people will always want to
bring up Maslow's hierarchy of needs not
quite the same thing as the hierarchy of
values this is the values that we Accord
to things and what we're willing to
sacrifice for others
so she says sacrifice is the surrender
of a greater value for the sake of a
lesser one or of a non value which is
you know actually different than what
Schaller says about this but we go on so
she says that the rational principle of
conduct is always act in accordance with
the hierarchy of your values never
sacrifice a greater value to a lesser
one so you know what might be the things
that we value this tie I've had it for a
long time it's pleasing to me in its
color and I like the way that it fits so
there's an aesthetic value that it has
it also has a certain use value I know
that if I need to go into a formal
situation I can wear this tie and it's
going to be durable and it's not gonna
let me down right the stuff in the back
hasn't come apart even though this this
tie is been in a lot of places it's gone
you know from one place to another to
another
I've had this probably for 15 to 20
years
but if called upon to sacrifice this tie
for the opportunity to I don't know
study with Julia on us great virtue
ethicist probably once in a lifetime
opportunity
I should like throw the tie off
immediately and say I'm going for that
if you know somebody is like
you pick one or the other and I'm like
well I don't know really is a nice tie
there's something wrong with me then and
we can say the same thing about our
relationships with persons in terms of
love and friendship Rand is perfectly
fine with saying that we should in fact
sacrifice it not in the sense of
betraying a higher value for a lower
value but in the ordinary sense of you
know saying well I'm gonna give this
thing up we should be willing to give a
lot of things up for the sake of love
and friendship if we really value that
person and if that person really does
deserve it provided we're not deceiving
ourself and thinking that just because
we enjoy sleeping with somebody that
they're thereby a good person how many
of us have made that mistake in the past
right there are so many people who lack
integrity and justice and in those
senses that we wind up being involved in
now she also discusses in other places
this figure of the traitor and I think
that can be useful in thinking about
love and friendship because love and
friendship as so many philosophers have
put it out there are some transactional
elements to it where you give something
in order to get something back or you
give with the expectation that it may
not you know directly result from that
but they'd also better show some
reciprocity to you so if you are a
attentive generous
you know amiable lover well then you
you've got a right to expect that from
the other person if they don't give it
to you then maybe you break off the
relationship right because they're not
showing themself as the kind of person
who has the same values as you a friend
who doesn't answer your texts and calls
there is a problem there a lack of
attentiveness right the person who's
always flaking out on you you don't have
to be friends with them necess
right so there there is a kind of
reciprocity or transactionality that's
involved in what Rand would call genuine
love or friendship which he takes as
being something quite different than the
ordinary view of things so this is rands
view on what friendship and love really
are about it has to do with with valuing
and you know it's a different view than
the common view but it does manage to
address a lot of the worries and
criticisms that people have about egoism
making the other person merely
instrumental and not valuing them in in
their own right as a person there's
there's something more to Rand than just
saying well everybody's just there for
my own satisfaction the way a crude
egoism might frame it
you